vous remercie d'être en direct avec nous
sur rt france alors beaucoup de
suppositions sur le rôle présumé de ce
scientifique
quel rôle joue est il exactement bonsoir
merci de m'avoir invité
donc en fait c'était un des pères du
nickel du nucléaire iranien mais ce
n'était pas le seul père puisque vous
savez donc le système nucléaire c'est un
système complexe et ça fait comme vous
l'avez déjà fait depuis une douzaine
d'années que des israéliens assassinent
continuellement des scientifiques
iraniens mais cela n'empêche pas le
régime iranien d'accéder de se
rapprocher de plus en de plus près du
système nucléaire
ça fait 12 ans qu'ils assassinent des
scientifiques iraniens et puis le régime
continue à avancer vers le versus ce
programme nucléaire pourquoi ils ont
fait ça telle est la question
alors justement martine faraday était
dans la ligne de mire un d'israël depuis
plusieurs années vous venez de dire
israël serait donc lié à cet assassinat
c'est en tout cas ce que pense l iran
est ce que selon vous c'est le scénario
le plus envisageable mais côté c'est le
sénat plus probable puisque en 2018
quand vous avez montré le premier
ministre et néry natalio avait déjà
parlé de du docteur montserrat résonnait
comme étant un des pères du nucléaire
iranien il a admis qu'il allait les
associés de l'assassiner mais comme je
vous ai dit ça fait une douzaine
d'années que l'israël conduit assassines
des scientifiques iraniens
est ce que cherche en fait israël c'est
à retarder le programme lui porte le
programme nucléaire iranien mais est ce
qu'ils vont pouvoir de chiens ou pas
sérieux on ne sait pas alors justement
monsieur roy nice s'est engagé à ce que
cette disparition je cite ne perturbe
pas les progrès scientifiques de l'iran
justement au niveau du programme
nucléaire de l'iran on en est où
actuellement donnée à ce que l'iran est
en train de réfléchir à sa réponse que
doit fuir l'iran soit l'iran ne reste
pas dans ce cas l'israël et à votre
conséquence les américains ont gagné
puisque encore une fois ils ont
assassinat un scientifique iranien et
les iraniens n'ont pas riposté
est-ce qu'ils répondent qu'il repose
tout de suite et de manière très forte
dans ce cas là ça donne une excuse à
l'administration américaine et plus
exactement à l'administration de donald
trump qui sont dans cette période de
transition de mener une action très
fortes contre l'iran et de mettre une
épine dans le pied du futur président le
président biden pour sa renégociation
avec les rangs soit l'iran fait comme
ils savent très bien le faire attendre
un certain temps et pouvoir riposter de
manière un peu plus réfléchi et dans ce
calme et encore ça sera une épine dans
le pied de l'administration mbaye dème
puisque les puisque le président
américain a promis qu'il allait
rejoindre le programme nucléaire iranien
et que les iraniens eux mêmes de leur
côté ont dit et ont souhaité qu' que les
américains rejoindre le programme
nucléaire iranien et que les iraniens
continuera à respecter leurs obligations
nucléaires
alors elle est justement la récente
élection de dubaï donne à la maison
blanche à ce que ça va vraiment changer
la donne
est ce que ça va changer je pense que ça
va changer puisque le futur président
bak den a dit qu'il allait rejoindre le
programme nucléaire iranien
programme duquel le président tron a été
sorti il ya quelques années est d'autant
plus qu'il va le rejoindre puisqu'il
était vice-président du président obama
johansson était vice-président américain
et s'était il était un des négociateurs
de ce programme avec deux ministres des
affaires étrangères de sécréter
architectes john kerry et il l'a dit à
plusieurs reprises qu'il allait
rejoindre ce programme iranien est
récemment sorti face aux stars son chef
de cabinet monsieur klein a dit que les
états unis souhaitaient rejoindre ce
programme pour pouvoir négocier avec
l'iran c'est de sortie du nucléaire pour
que l'iran ne puissent pas accéder à
l'armé nucléaire
est ce qu'ils vont pouvoir le faire on
sait pas la question est ce qui va
qu'est ce qu'il est arrivé en iran
puisqu'on iront en demi en juin 2021
nous allons avoir de nouvelles élections
présidentielles et que les conservateurs
ont beaucoup davantage
actuellement en iran puisqu'ils disent
que les modérés ont essayé de négocier
un accord avec des américains les
américaines ne tiennent pas parole
ils sont sortis unilatéralement de cet
accord nucléaire et des conservateurs
essayer de jouer là-dessus pour dire si
jamais il gagne qu'on nous on nous
allons sortir de cet accord et
dernièrement le parlement iranien essaie
de voter en fait une loi pour empêcher
les inspecteurs de l'organisation
internationale attendait d'eux d'accéder
aux sites nucléaires iraniens
alors très rapidement monsieur chamoux
ans les propos officiels de l'iran en
temps et en heure les ennemis de l'iran
répondra à ce crime
beaucoup de pays justement appel à la
retenue est ce que selon vous cet
assassinat allume un peu le feu s'est
rallumée un peu le feu ça rappelle en
fait ce qu'on fait les américains quand
ils ont été pas quand ils ont tué le
général soliman et si vous vous rappelez
bien les iraniens ont riposté en
envoyant des missiles contre une base
aérienne militaire américain en irak
mais juste avant il allait il avait pris
le soin de prévenir les américains en
disant qu'ils allaient riposté sur cette
base pour que les américains puissent
faire sortir leurs soldats pour qu'il
n'y ait pas de décès américains il ya eu
certes beaucoup de beaucoup de blessés
mais les iraniens avaient riposté et
dans ce cas là encore comme la ville de
président à vie ils vont riposter de
manière plus ou moins intelligentes
quand on sait pas mais c'est sûr et
certain que les iraniens la république
l'année continuellement riposte quand
ils font l'objet d'une attaque comme le
font les israéliens ou comme le font des
américains et je pense que les iraniens
vont répondre
de plus si jamais il ya un conservateur
qui est élu ils vont répondre de manière
beaucoup plus forte
vous savez qu'il ya des journaux
iraniens des conservateurs qui disent
qu'il faut attaquer le port de haïfa
avec des missiles iraniens il y en a
d'autres qui disent qu'il faut passer
via le hezbollah de l'autre le parti le
parti chiite libanais pour faire des
affaires sur le nord d'israël et
d'autres qui disent qu'il faut se venger
et riposté en série puisqu'il ya une
guerre depuis un certain temps entre
l'iran et l'israël en série qui se
déroule depuis des années comment vous
voyez alors à la suite d
evènement à la suite des événements je
pense que j'irais bien pour l'instant
ils vont attendre
ils vont attendre que ces prêts période
de transition se termine
puisque pour que l'administration byden
prennent le pouvoir et observer ce que
affirme byden sibide elle souhaite
rejoindre le programme nucléaire iranien
je pense que les rnr vont ne vend rien
faire ils vont attendre pour qu' il y
ait une aide économique puisque
l'économie et iranien est en pleine
crise et que si jamais les américains ne
rejoigne quand cet accord nucléaire pour
que les européens et les autres pays du
monde puissent investir en iran
l'économie l'économie du pays va
s'effondrer
mais si jamais joe biden qui est
également proche du pré du premier
ministre n'a pas néo ne rejoindra cet
accord nucléaire dans ce cas il ya un
vrai risque de conflit l'iran peut peut
riposter et ils vont sûrement riposté
par la boîte du hezbollah ce que je
pense
pour pouvoir embourbé les israéliens
puisque les israéliens vont avoir le
choix soit avec l'iran directement soit
l'attaqué le liban et de rentrer au
liban comme il l'avait fait il ya
plusieurs années et ils ont dû se
retirer parce que dans le bourbier
libanais surtout monde bourbier de ce
sud du liban
c'est très dur de mener un conflit est
directement monsieur sam nous voient pas
que vous êtes avocat franco iranien
merci d'avoir été avec nous en direct
sur arte france